The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The
logistics for the class.
Unfortunately, we seem
to have run out a bit.
So if you could share the
syllabus that you have.
I'm actually not going
to go over it in detail.
I do want to give you sort
of the big picture of what
we're doing.
First of all, I'm
glad you're here.
And I do want class
participation.
There will be three problem
sets and a research proposal.
The problem sets are
meant to be practice
for you just to make sure you're
working through the material.
Some of you take field
exams, for example.
So these problem sets are
meant to be practices for that,
as well.
It's really meant to help you.
One of the problem sets is going
to focus on actually getting
your hands dirty with
the data, so to speak,
and Whit's going
to help with that
and give you access to
the Townsend tie data.
And we'll have a specific
project geared around that.
It's really a research
class so, I would like you
to write a research proposal.
Not exactly a paper--
it can be short.
But the idea is
that hopefully as we
go through these
lectures, you will--
and I will try to
help this process--
you'll have ideas
about things you
would like to work
on, things where
you think the literature
is falling short.
And you should begin to
sort of think about that.
It's all too easy
in these courses
to think that taking a course
means memorizing the lecture
notes or learning
how to manipulate
as in a certain model,
and not thinking broadly
about next steps.
You don't see faculty doing
the research, actually.
I'm going to try to share with
you how literatures develop,
compare and contrast different
styles, different attack
strategies.
In fact, the lectures
are going to be
a blend between
overview material
and the usual detailed
analysis of specific papers.
Because that's a big
part of the course,
I want you to get
some experience
at trying to think about
things that way, as well.
The syllabus does say
something about a midterm,
which is basically the final
for my half of the course.
This is joint with Abhijit.
But my first gift to you is
that we're going to waive that.
So there will be no final exam.
And instead, the
emphasis is going
to be on the problem sets,
and the research proposal,
and class participation.
Before I forget to say,
the recitation section
is scheduled Thursdays.
I had originally
thought it was Fridays.
So we put To Be Determined in
all those recitation sections.
And in fact, by this Thursday
noon-- just after this class,
essentially--
you would have already had
your first recitation section.
But it's just too
early, so we're not
going to meet on Thursday.
But we will start in
earnest the following week.
And if you start
looking at the syllabus,
you will see that
there's a section
at the beginning on data, which
I've kind of already mentioned.
There's a section at the
beginning on computation,
and also on the GIS.
So if you want to think about
those as tools or skills,
we're going to have
some TA sessions going
over sort of some of the
computational aspects,
for example, after the
lecture on Thursday.
Though it will be obvious how
a computational recitation
section fits in.
Now I recognize I don't
want to overdo this,
but the more I've talked
to many of you, the more--
including yesterday,
actually, in some sense,
and advising of second years--
the more I realized
that students like
you want to get trained
in computational skills
and methods, and so on.
So we can have some
extra sessions.
I'm in the busy--
in the process of setting up
extra computational sections
on how to solve
certain problems.
We'll probably make up for the
lost TA session on Thursday.
And Whit, in fact,
is going to send out
an email to each of
you to try to work
on scheduling a backup time.
So if we have some
extra sessions,
we'll try to have as few
conflicts as possible
so you can come.
So I guess the only thing I want
to say about the syllabus that
won't be obvious
from the lecture is
today is the introductory
class, and there's all
this supplementary material.
And then on Thursday,
we'll start with Lecture 2.
You'll get a dose of these sort
of micro-founded macro models.
We're going to go
on to another sort
of new wave of those models
featuring limited commitment
and collateral constraints on
the growth TSP type issues.
And then another section
focuses on basically versions
where there's costly state
verification, or moral hazard,
or adverse selection.
So you can compare and
contrast the implications
of having these different
financial underpinnings.
Which you know is
complementary classes in macro
are also getting at
those same issues.
Then we'll have sort of the
intermediate class on microdata
and building all the way
from household accounts
to national income
accounts, and then
move to actually using the
microdata for various tests
so that these models, full
insurance, in various ways,
then with these
obstacles to trade
and so on throughout the class.
So that's kind of the big
picture of the syllabus.
Each lecture is pretty--
a lot of fun.
And there's a lot of
material in there.
The lecture notes are
meant, as I've said,
to tie the material
together both in general,
and in its specifics.
Today is a little
bit of an exception
because it's just an
introductory lecture.
I will try to have
all the slides posted.
I'm not sure we managed
to get this thing posted,
but I'll do that.
I'll try to get that
done right after class.
Normally the slides will be
posted in advance of the class.
So if you feel more comfortable
looking at material,
might facilitate asking
questions during class,
which would be good.
AUDIENCE: These
slides are posted.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Oh, good.
Excellent.
And most of the readings
are linked, not entirely
all of them.
So it should be easy to
explore your special topic.
Are there questions about
the logistics of the class?
And I'll hang around
a bit afterwards
to answer any specific
questions you might have.
So finance, growth,
and volatility--
theory, data, and the
formulation of policy.
You know, the course is
organized around these topics.
There's so many ways
to think about this.
Finance, financial access is a
very huge issue in development.
You may be more used
to thinking about it
from a micro perspective.
But we not only do the
micro, we do the macro.
The idea is that somehow
finance helps people
with financial services.
It may be alleviating
poverty, and in the context
of these general
equilibrium models,
it has additional effects.
So many countries
around the world,
not just the World Bank
and other aid agencies,
are pushing, promoting,
advocating, financial access.
There's new Gallup surveys
measuring this stuff
to try to get at inequalities
across countries,
to sort of push a
little bit the agenda.
So that's finance and growth.
I'm going to say
more in a second.
Finance and volatility
sort of should
bring to mind the recent US
and worldwide financial crisis.
And it pushes you seemingly in
exactly the opposite direction,
which is maybe the
housing market in the US.
Maybe there was a
little too much effort
for middle or even lower
income households to own homes,
and that's led to certain
government agency financing
arrangements.
And in any event, it clearly
was a financial crisis.
And most of the regulations
deal with seemingly trying
to push us back toward more
restricted intermediation,
as if financial
access, and credit,
and financial
liberalization might,
if not be a bad thing,
maybe go too far.
Well, we're going to try
to be writing down models
that think about not only
each of those separately,
but to some extent,
having it on the same page
to try to get at that tension.
And actually growth is in
there with finance and growth.
Growth and volatility is
another quote bilateral
pairing if you wish.
There's some idea that
finance causes growth,
but growth does not
come without volatility,
leaving the question
I just raised
about finance and volatility.
So let me sort of
give you a sense
of each of these sub-pieces.
Finance and growth,
well, here's the story,
and I think it's pretty well
accepted by these three papers,
for example, that
are very much cited,
King and Levine, Rajan and
Zingales, and Ross Levine.
You can read the
abstract, but basically,
let's pick out a
few things here.
Finance and Growth,
Schumpeter Might be Right.
Cross country evidence that
financial systems promote
growth, that the levels
of financial development
are strongly associated
with per capita GDP growth,
and capital accumulations and
improvements in efficiency
like TFP.
But furthermore, there seems
to be causality in the data,
that predetermined level
of financial deepening
or development are associated
with subsequent higher
rates of all these good things.
Rajan and Zingales come
at it in a related way.
They're basically saying
that industrial sectors that
are more in need
of external finance
due to the nature
of the business
develop disproportionately
faster starting
from a lower level in countries
where the financial systems are
liberalized or more liberal
than in other countries.
And they're worried about
causality and so forth.
And Levine's review, Finance
and Growth, Theory and Evidence,
the summary in the abstract
with qualifications
to follow from him.
Countries with better
functioning banks grow faster,
but however, it
doesn't seem to matter
whether it's bank-led finance
or stocks or equity markets.
He tries to cover the
literature on simultaneity bias,
and so on.
So Levine also points
out the importance
of this question
and the importance,
therefore, to research.
And I must say,
in these slides I
tried to indicate where there
were quotes, but at some point
you may find it
hard to tell what
was the author's statement,
which is quite clear here,
versus my summary.
But I wanted to see--
I didn't want you have
to take my word for it.
I actually wanted you to
see what these guys are
saying in their papers.
"Research that clarifies
our understanding
of the role of finance
and economic growth
have policy
implications and shape
policy-oriented research."
This is going to influence
the priority that policymakers
and advisors attach to reforming
the financial service sector.
And so when this
empirical work shows
there is the connection between
finance and long-run growth,
that basically advertises
the urgent need
for research on the political,
legal, regulatory, or policy
determinants of
financial development.
Note he is not saying
that it's a done deal.
And he has been one of
the lead contributors
to this empirical work.
But he's saying, in
fact, there is much more
to do on the research side.
Specific policy implications
are not immediate.
It's not obvious how to go
from the general idea of policy
to the way that financial
systems actually work,
and in particular, the
way they are modeled
at the theoretical level.
So you'll see this over and over
again in these lectures, which
is this--
and I try to bring
out both sides--
which is empirical work seems
to mesmerize, if not reassure
theoretical work with almost
no mention to the data
and often this gap in between.
I'm going to try
to bridge the gap,
show you how the literature
is trying to bridge the gap.
But it's kind of reassuring
and refreshing to see
Levine being so candid in this
rather famous review article.
He says, "What do financial
intermediaries really do?"
Well, you can think about
producing information,
about investment possibilities,
or monitoring investments,
maybe corporate
governance is better
if they're somebody looking
at them, facilitate trading.
Facilitate diversification
is important
when there's risk for sure and
the management of that risk.
Financial systems at
a theoretical level
mobilize and pool savings and
generally ease the exchange
of goods and services.
So changes in these functions
that are brought about
by, say, policy
changes could influence
savings and investment,
and therefore,
have influence on
economic growth.
Now, then you start to think
about what is he really
saying or not saying?
One thing that sort of
caught my attention--
and I was predisposed
to look for it--
is this distinction about
levels versus growth rates.
So is his vision one
of steadily improving
financial intermediation on one
or several of these dimensions,
pushing levels of income
up, so that an expanding
improved financial
sector over time
is causing growth in
the sense that you
have ever-increasing levels?
Or is he saying that
a once-and-for-all fix
to the financial system, making
it go from a lower or higher
level, and no changes after
that have an implication
for sustained growth as
in quote, steady state?
Not clear from what he said.
And we'll see models that take
both these tacts actually.
There are other sort of
caveats when you think
about theoretical modeling.
Are we talking about
technological improvement
in the sense of TFP?
Is that really what
improved intermediation
is supposed to be giving us?
But again, we should
maybe think also
about transitions or even
potentially poverty traps
if systems get stuck.
Another caveat,
savings rates are not
monotone with
increases in return.
I mean, for one thing,
in price theory,
just think about income
and substitution effects.
One cuts against the other one.
Or what about the
relationships between savings
and improved allocation of risk?
If you improve the
allocation of risk bearing,
then you don't need to
save as a buffer stock.
So savings may actually
go down and not up
as a consequence
of improving one
piece of the financial system.
And then he makes his
pitch for thinking about--
don't think broadly about
savings or especially credit
as an input.
Think about actually
how the financial system
is put together.
And we'll come back to
that, especially when we
get to the measurement part.
Does finance cause
reduced inequality?
He said in this review,
not necessarily.
And he reviews
empirical evidence.
There are theoretical models
that claim this to be true,
that the relationship is, say,
favorable to reduce poverty,
reduce inequality, and so on.
But certainly, in some of
the theoretical models--
in some of them that
we're going to cover--
improved financial
systems, at least early on,
cause increases in inequality,
not decreases in inequality.
Something along
the lines of what
Kuznets had in mind, actually.
And then he just goes
through some empirical work
and doesn't come back.
Not to belittle it, but
he does not come back
to this underlying tension.
Volatility and growth.
Let's see.
Before we start thinking that
all the volatility we see
has something to do with finance
or unstable financial systems,
maybe we should try to
document better those sources.
So this paper in the
QJE is a decomposition
of the sources of inequality,
looking in particular
at low income countries.
Take it as a fact--
I'll show you a graph
momentarily from them--
that there is more volatility
in growth rates among low income
countries.
And why is that happening?
Could be that poor countries
somehow or other end up
specialized in volatile sectors.
Or it could be a
version of that,
they just have a lot more
quote, specialization.
They're not terribly
diversified over a multitude
of different sectors.
Could be that poor
countries experience
more frequent or more
severe aggregate shocks
sort of from a macro
policy perspective.
And it's even possible that
poor countries experienced macro
fluctuations that are somehow
correlated with the shocks
in which they're--
the sectors in which
they're specialized.
So here's the picture.
This is levels of per
capita GDP and the variance.
Standard deviation
calculation, this morning,
sort of thinking
about this lecture,
I spooked myself a bit worrying
that it should have been
growth rates and not levels.
But actually when
they do the analysis,
they do a composition in
the growth of value added.
Again, I can't do justice
to this paper other
than give you an overview.
But what they're saying is that
the growth of GDP per worker
in country J, this object
here, is a weighted average
of the growth of GDP
in the various sectors
in which country
J is specialized.
And these AJs are the
weights or the proportions.
And then they write down a quite
plausible statistical model
that the growth of value
added GDP per worker
in sector J of country S has a
country S component, a sector J
component, and some residual.
So that's kind of
the basic model.
And what they do then is
a very clever, basically,
variance co-variance
decomposition
quantifying and answering
the questions that were
raised on the previous slide.
The answer is 60% of this
volatility is country specific.
So I don't know how you
want to think about that.
It's not even 50-50.
More than half of it is somehow
a country specific phenomenon.
On the other hand, there's a
very non-trivial residual 40%--
almost 50, say-- which
is due to the following,
namely diversification
is limited
in low income countries.
And low income countries do
tend to specialize in sectors
that are relatively volatile.
That sets aside
the issue of why,
and whether there are any
possible remedies, and so on.
A Model in which
Volatility is Inevitable.
This is one of Daron's
models with Zilibotti.
It's a great paper.
And the idea is simple,
but very clever,
which is basically there is
a fixed cost to opening up
a new sector.
And at any moment
in time, of course,
you have a limited
amount of resources.
So you've got to choose--
you can't literally
afford to do everything.
You can only do a
subset of things.
So you're naturally vulnerable
to shocks in technologies
that can't cover your--
that are not able
to cover your risk.
Now within that there
are some policy issues
we might come back
to at some point.
But for a while,
clearly, these countries
are going to just be more
volatile, because they're
less able to diversify.
Then it gets a little more--
what should I say--
provocative.
Which is, maybe
volatility is actually
not something you'd
like to get rid of
and eventually can
afford to do it.
Maybe it's actually a necessary
ingredient for growth.
In other words, if we come back
to the big motivation, the idea
that finance causes
growth, OK, let's do it.
And finance and macro
stability, well, maybe you're
going to have the
downside of that,
that there has to be some
instability if you're
going to get the growth.
If you think this is
entirely provocative,
just think about
the mean variance
idea of holding assets.
You don't get a
higher mean for free.
Higher means come
with more risk.
So we should maybe
take this seriously,
as did these authors.
I think this is in the QJE.
And they document
that countries that
have had occasional
financial crises
do grow faster on average.
How did they measure
that basically risk idea?
Well, they don't want to take
a simple variance measure,
because that's like small
or big, left or right tail.
It doesn't matter.
They're trying to
get at a crisis.
So their ideas look at
the growth of credit,
or actually quite negative
growth, when you have a bust.
First, the boom, maybe
inching along, maybe a trend.
Who knows how fast?
But occasionally, wham, you
get one of these episodes where
the bottom falls out.
And I can't help but
say, it's a bit odd
that since the US had a
recent financial crisis,
everyone's kind of tearing
up all the old work
and starting over as if we
need a whole new agenda.
Whereas, countries
throughout the world
for, Rogoff would
say, hundreds of years
have been experiencing
financial crises.
So certainly we
should pay attention.
Not to say something's
good or bad,
but there's lots of
historical experience.
So they look at the
skewness of credit growth.
I always get the sign wrong,
but positive basically
puts the mass in the left tail.
And they actually have
a little model, which
I'll come back to in a second.
So here are some pictures.
India versus Thailand, real
credit growth and GDP growth.
So the dotted line is Thailand,
which way back to 1980,
was expanding its
financial system
as measured by real credit.
And then this is the
famous, if not infamous,
infamous financial crisis
that started in July 2, 1997,
when the Bank of Thailand
realized it couldn't continue
to hold the exchange
rate because they
had forward commitments they
seem to have forgot about.
And that spread, as you
know, to many, not all,
but many of the Asian countries,
not even nearby countries.
I mean, Korea is not near,
but they too suffered.
However, if you look
at the-- and India
did not have this crisis.
And India has been
bragging a lot lately
how clever they were to be
conservative that they did not
suffer from the US
financial episode
the way some other
countries have had.
But if you look at the big
picture, here at least,
up through 02, you can see
Thailand has kind of this
V-shaped drop, and then
it's right back on.
My measurements show
that the growth rate was
only 4% after as opposed
to 5% or 6% before,
so maybe there was
a structural shift.
But this little drop doesn't
affect the overall level,
India's level remains lower.
So during this period,
country of Thailand
was one of the fastest growing
countries in the world.
You hear a lot about
China now and, rightly so,
India actually, also.
But this is a big--
and I didn't realize that these
guys had focused on Thailand.
We have a lot more to say
about Thailand in the class,
but obviously we're not alone
in thinking about Thailand
relative to other countries.
Now whether I agree with them
about the financial crisis is--
or that dip is-- another story.
Now how does their model work?
Actually, the paper
uses this as motivation
and then goes on
to try to work out
how you would find
countries experiencing
these periodic financial crises.
So the idea is it's a
credit constraint model.
So there are
borrowing constraints
like collateral constraints.
And if they were locked in
place without any leniency,
you'd have high return
businesses starved for credit.
But what happens is people
begin to anticipate that
actually they can be more
generous in their lending
because of the moral--
so-called moral hazard problem,
which is the government's going
to bail them out--
so bail out the private sector.
So this is sort of a
political economy story.
There's kind of like a political
economy-driven boom-bust cycle.
Now, again, I don't
have the equations here,
but the paper's online and you
can read through their model.
So they're saying
crises are costly.
They're associated
with bankruptcies
and a dead-weight loss.
And it's true that
when a crisis happens,
you get this depressing
effect on new credit,
and on investment,
and hampering growth,
which is a big
conversation in the US,
and actually, to some
extent in Europe.
And they're saying if
their model is right--
or they believe they're right--
that this sort of effect
is going to be larger in
countries where the contract
enforceability issues are
more severe like borrowing
constraints.
On the other hand,
not too severe,
otherwise they won't get
this leverage effect.
So then we come to
the trilogy which
is finance and volatility.
We did finance and growth,
growth and volatility,
now finance and volatility.
And I don't have too much
more to say about this other
than to offer the reminder
that that Acemoglu
paper and the
Ranciere et al paper
suggest that volatility might
diminish over time as countries
have higher and higher
level of output.
But as I said at the
beginning, in fact,
not all these sort of--
it must be more than a
bunch-- it must be more
than the transitivity.
If A is associated with B, and
B is associated with C, than A
should be associated
with C. And in the data,
it doesn't go that way.
So clearly there's something
being left out here.
This paper, which I became
aware of more recently--
and they seem to find that, in
fact, deeper financial systems
are associated with
lower volatility.
But I checked this
again this morning,
they also have in
the regression,
the levels of income and
the growth rates of income.
So in other words,
they have to control
for the other parts
of the trilogy,
basically, and then
eek out this effect.
Countries that are poor are
often dependent on trade.
There are problems when
exchange rates move.
There are issues about
devaluations, and so on.
So they kind of have to
control for all of that.
And then offer the
suggestion that finance
might be a good thing.
But believe me,
countries don't know.
The IMF really
doesn't know either,
and they're very interested
in the state of the literature
and in further research
to try to find out.
Because they have
client countries
who want to know what to do.
They go to the IMF, for
example, to get advice.
So then we come to this
sort of policy discussion
that's going on today.
And to be candid, it
seems to basically
depart from this
literature, from both
the theoretical and the
empirical literature.
Levine writes a new
paper now called
Regulating Finance and
Regulators to Promote Growth.
It's like, well, we
got to fix the problem.
We know the financial crisis
was caused by bad regulation,
so let's jump in and
regulate somehow or provide
the right incentives.
So how important is it that the
operation of-- how important
is the operation of
the financial system
for an economic growth?
And which financial regulatory
reforms will improve
financial sector operations?
He's sort of assuming, in
some sense, an the answer
that the other literature is,
and his own review was sort of
much more equivocal about.
This is another example,
this Thorsten Beck's work,
which is highly regarded,
I think, in policy circles.
And the idea is to come up
with a financial possibilities
frontier.
And again, this is
driven by the idea
that we're going
to give countries
specific recommendations.
They want to know where
they stand relative
to other countries, and what, if
anything, they should be doing.
So here's the idea.
This is the, say, the financial
possibilities frontier.
This country is in on it.
So somehow they
should move up there.
This country B actually
has a higher level
of financial depth than A.
But rather than rest
on their levels,
the idea is that if we knew
what this frontier was,
it would tell us
they're actually further
below the frontier than A was.
They have more ground to go
to get up to that frontier.
And then this will get your
eye here beyond the frontier.
So the idea is that
some countries are just
basically too deep, and
they should pull back.
AUDIENCE: Question.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In this paper,
what sort of things
go on the x-axis?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
so this is basically
a huge sort of cross-country
regression with tons
of x-variables.
The next slide has--
gives you some sense.
There are variables in there
to try to control somehow
for institutions.
There are surveys of how easy
it is to conduct business
in these countries.
There are other
things associated
with structural problems.
There is even policy
stuff, although honestly, I
don't remember.
We can look it up and
see, sort of categorize
all the x-variables.
Now, I'm somewhat sympathetic
to looking at data.
So we don't want to say this
is completely uninformative.
And I am sympathetic
with the idea
that knowing what has happened
to different countries
at different points in
times might kind of give us
pause, like leading indicators.
There's a whole group.
Actually, I was talking to
Ken Singleton the other day,
and I don't think this
work is quite public yet,
but there the idea is he's in
finance and a very good person.
And he's trying to
measure the risk premium
based on observed asset prices.
And they seem to be showing that
when the risk premium is low,
that's when you
run into trouble.
Now that might sound like
counterintuitive at first,
but the point is, if the markets
are saying, or understating,
the amount of risk, then you
can imagine the financial system
is just pumping too much money
into otherwise risky things.
And that's when countries
run into trouble eventually.
So it's good to have early
warnings, that's good.
But that seems to me
the challenge here
is to get beneath the frontier.
In fact, I find the whole
jargon a bit misleading,
because there is a utility
possibilities frontier which
is like the bread and butter of
general equilibrium economics.
One point is you can't
get beyond the frontier.
Anyway, there's a question.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was going
to ask, in what sense
does he talk about frontier?
Because it sort of
looks from his graph
as if he was saying this
is the optimal level
of financial deepening for you.
That's not what
a frontier means.
So then he's talking
about pareto optimality.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No, that's me.
So this is one instance
where my thoughts kind of
merged into his, so
I'm the one worried
about pareto optimality.
AUDIENCE: So are there issues
with aggregation at that point,
if you're worrying about
utility possibilities
frontiers and pareto
optimality and stuff?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: To construct a
utility possibilities frontier,
we need to specify the model.
We're going to have to layout
preferences, endowments,
and technology.
We're going to have
to take a stand
on possible imperfections in
the credit and financial system.
And just say that
sometimes it will turn out
that despite limited commitment
or some information problems,
it's a well-defined notion,
and markets should allow
you to end up on the frontier.
But there are other things like
pecuniary externalities, where
if there is no remedy,
then you could end up
off the frontier due
to an externality.
So something close
to the same language
works, but if I'm
understanding you correctly,
they're not representative
consumer models, typically.
They have all the
heterogeneity in them,
and there are issues
about whether there
is a pseudo representative
consumer that somehow
approximates the behavior.
So those are key
issues in these models.
And most of them don't
aggregate up that way.
But on the other
hand, we can look
at the welfare implications.
And finally,
there's this paper--
an IMF working paper--
on how to deal
with credit booms.
And this seems to be a summary
of the current consensus.
I hesitate to call it that.
That credit booms, buttress,
investment and consumption,
they can contribute
to long run deepening,
but they often end up in costly
balance sheet disallocations,
and dislocations, and more
often than acceptable,
in devastating financial
crises whose cost greatly
exceeds the benefit
associated with boom.
So this is the view somehow
that is pretty typical.
And so you end up
with this sort of goal
to keep an eye on
financial liberalizations
to limit credit
expansion somehow,
although they don't
quite know how.
And the menu of things
that they're looking at
is very Basile like.
They're basically ad hoc
international best practice
statements.
As if it were obvious how to
regulate the financial system.
Those regulations are not coming
from fundamental considerations
of how credit markets
work, and how they interact
with the macro economy.
So is there another way,
an alternative approach?
I guess it's
self-evident from what
I've been saying in this
introduction is to understand
something I'm going to refer
to short-handedly as Applied
General Equilibrium Development
Economics to understand
the unit of analysis at
which this can be applied,
and to clarify what that is
relative to other general
equilibrium models
in the literature.
So this may be a familiar,
if shocking, picture,
so to speak, in the context.
If you haven't seen
it before, this
is a picture of a
village in India.
We can enumerate the
household by their wealth,
order them by their wealth,
and look at these years
where panel data were gathered
in these so-called ICRISAT
villages.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
And here you can see the
ups and downs of income.
Idiosyncratic
aggregate risk, there's
not a lot of co-movement here.
The peaks are covering
up the valleys behind it.
Households are not having up
and ups and downs together.
There's plenty of
risk in the system.
And this is how the
consumption picture turns out.
I often refer to this
in a shorthand way
as the Rocky Mountains
versus Kansas.
And Kansas is pretty boring.
It's very flat.
But what it shows you very
dramatically is that somehow,
some way, in these
village economies,
they have figured out a way
to smooth a lot of the risk.
In fact, they come very close--
not totally there--
but very close
to achieving the
optimal allocation
of risk-bearing that
Arrow-Debreu and so on
have been talking about.
Now don't dismiss this
as OK, OK, we're back.
And thank God it's development.
We're back in villages.
The point is that you
can use this framework
and the data are available to
do this not just at the village
level, collections of villages,
regions in the country,
or even across countries.
And every single one of
those things is done,
and there's a huge literature.
So we know quite a bit about
the allocation of risk-bearing,
and in fact, where systems fail.
Here's another look
at sort of an economy.
This turns out to
be another village.
And it's about the
diversification issue.
So if you could do all this
great ex post smoothing
somehow, you should
just specialize
in what you're good at,
and your asset holdings
might appear pretty specialized.
And maybe the bulk
of your consumption
is determined ex post by
borrowing, and lending,
and gift-giving, and
whatever else they're doing.
But no, not in medieval England.
They divided up their land
in an extraordinary way.
A typical farmer would have
60 or 70 plots fragmented
throughout the village.
This is also true in Bolivia,
up in Altiplano and so on,
running down
different elevations.
So the point here is not
all economies are alike,
not even all villages are alike.
And looking at
data in this case,
partly through this
institution, you
can see that the ex post
allocation of risk-bearing
must evidently be more limited.
In this case, it took a
private information model
to try to explain that outcome.
Again, to reassure you that
this is not just macro,
it's macro development,
macro devo, devoted to macro,
or I don't know, you can
turn that any way you want.
[LAUGHTER]
Someone made a joke
once, if in the slides
you don't have a picture
of a villager or something,
then you're not really
a development economist.
I actually took this picture.
But so you got land,
labor, and capital.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So I love villages.
And the reason is, you really
don't have to make things up.
You can actually measure things
and get an approximate sense
of what the preference, the
endowments, and technology are.
Preferences are a bit trickier.
So that's the way the language
we use as general equilibrium
theorists--
preferences,
endowments, technology,
as I said in answer to
the earlier question.
And then you can do
this kind of adding up.
So this is like taking these
villages, the Thai villages,
and adding up all the
households in the village
with the financial accounts.
We'll get to that
in a minute, that's
the measurement part, the
midpoint of the course.
And you can see in one region
near Bangkok, village output--
GDP, except it's not national--
is going down.
In the other regions,
it's kind of going up.
This is a second
panel, so to speak,
is where their savings is
put into real or financial
investments.
And here you have
the balance payments.
So it shouldn't be
too much of a stretch
to realize that if you
have the measurement,
you can indeed zoom
in and zoom out.
You can go from households
out to the whole country,
and intermediate
steps in between,
and use these standard tools.
In this case, we've
ended up with the tools
that international
economists use,
I'm using them internally
within the country.
But at least if the
measurement is in common,
we are allowed to do that.
I'll just pause briefly
to talk about the data.
I've already
mentioned we have it,
and you should feel
free to use it.
It's quite extensive.
It's 15 years worth of data.
And some of it's monthly.
It's both rural and urban.
Yeah, I'm in city
neighborhoods and spread out
throughout the kingdom.
This is zooming in and
zooming out, literally.
So here you can see almost
like an aerial photo
with the village locations
where we collect data.
All the way over here you
can see zooming way out,
where it is basically.
It's somewhat near Bangkok,
this particular sample site,
and this is sort of
the intermediate level.
Here we're plotting at
the level of provinces
the wealth level, which is in
common with those two diagrams.
Well, we have this
extensive GIS system.
I've made a campaign of putting
all available secondary data
that I could get a hold of
over the years, a lot of it's
available through
Dataverse, Harvard MIT.
And we are in the
process of putting this
onto this common
GIS platform where
you can look at bank locations,
and factory locations, and road
networks, and compute
travel time, and so on.
So one of the--
if you're interested, I can
have my GIS person maybe
have a special session and
show you a little bit about how
to use this system and
the kind of work that's
possible to do with it.
It's coming.
There isn't that much
work in economics
that has explicit general
equilibrium spatial modeling,
but it's coming.
So it's a wide open and
interesting research topic.
So what is this general
equilibrium development
approach?
Well, it's not just
individual maximization.
It's not just
partial equilibrium.
It's general equilibrium.
So things like the economy-wide
interest rate and wage rates
are very much on our minds.
From a development
perspective, it's not just
the impact of some savings
account or improved credit
product on individuals, it's
about efficiency of the system.
In other words, it's not
just on the credit side,
it's kind of on
the lending side.
The money for lending
comes from savings.
You have to think
about intermediation
and the flow of funds,
and judge efficiency
using this pareto criterion.
It's not a foregone conclusion
what the best fitting market
or contract structure is.
That's something that
comes out of the analysis.
That's why it's so good
to have the micro data,
because you can actually test.
You could have village--
one village doing quite
well and a whole region
in another part of the
country doing terribly.
But we don't have
to guess or assume,
because we'll in the
course acquire some tools
for doing that analysis.
So clearly it's not the ever
varying Washington consensus,
which is for liberalization
and now for regulation.
Look at Europe, just going
back and forth not knowing
what to do.
The debt's too high.
We need to restrain it.
Oh, my God!
We need the stimulus.
So we think through those
things at the same time
with these models.
And I don't mean to be
saying it's all about the US,
obviously.
It's about India.
It's about the Philippines.
It's Kenya where they are
allowing cell phones as
opposed to Thailand where
they're effectively ruling it
out.
So those are the debates
that are happening
in developing countries.
You've got some stuff on the
website if you want to see.
I will be tracking
Thailand a lot,
but I've also been
writing a book on Mexico.
And you'll see me
throw in some slides.
I think the danger here is
you see too much Thailand,
and then you begin to think
it's all about Thailand.
Well, A, I'm not the only
one worrying about Thailand.
But B, seeing other countries
and seeing the same analysis
done in two different
countries really brings
this stuff to light.
So that's why
Mexico is sometimes
paired in these slides.
So the goal here
is to explain, yes,
to understand what's
out there, but it's also
normative to try to come
up with policies that
allow more inclusive
financial systems
if the data indicate that.
But also to think about
the overall efficiency,
and to think about market
design and optimal regulation.
There is some logic in
all of this, basically.
You assume something
or several things,
you go out there and test.
It may fit.
If it does fit,
you've understood
the financial contracts
and the imperfection.
If it's full information
for risk sharing,
then we have this
wonderful standard
and it's clear, at least at
the village level in India,
you shouldn't be intervening
with particular households.
On the other hand,
if you reject,
maybe it's due to a moral
hazard problem, the problem
that people don't repay
and they walk away
from their investments.
The data can help indicate that.
Now then the question is,
is it still constrained?
Maybe it's second best optimal.
Maybe this first best
standard is an illusion.
But maybe when it's
second best, things
like allowing more goods to
play the role as collateral,
like changing the legal
system, those kinds of reforms
might be indicated.
Now there is a lot of general
equilibrium literature
to sort of contrast with this
general equilibrium development
point of view.
This goes way back
to the foundations
of general equilibrium.
Herb Scarf, and his
students, Chauvin and Wally,
that's called Applied
General Equilibrium
and does not allow uncertainty.
This type of modeling
is still used,
although it's in
kind of pockets.
It's used within the World Bank.
All our climate guys over
here at MIT use this stuff.
That's the basic conceptual
framework, the CGE model,
that lies behind these
conclusions about how
climate change is going
to influence the economy.
So it is quite widely used.
And there's some
great review articles.
And it does have
some key strengths.
Computable General
Equilibrium has this strength
of drawing on the national
income and product accounts
and input-output matrices.
That's basically the successor
to the Supply General
Equilibrium.
And then we have the more
macro-like, if I could say
so, Dynamic Stochastic
General Equilibrium models.
So you associate this with
Prescott, for example,
and real business cycles.
So it's great on dynamics.
It's great in being
very clear about shocks.
However, we anticipated
this, it largely
assumes a
representative consumer.
As if you had complete markets
that allow this kind of Gorman
aggregation with
certain preferences.
So in that world,
you're not going
to have redistributive
wealth effects.
And it is kind of
interesting in sort
of a history of
thought point of view,
that despite the early
battles in macro,
this DSGE stuff basically
took over, and largely
without modeling the
financial sector.
And so I think that's why people
felt rather flat-footed when
the financial crisis came along.
So there is stuff, sort of
dynamic general equilibrium
models that started with
Bernanke and Gertler.
I keep looking at Alp
over there because I
know that we feature that
just now in the macro lecture.
It is kind of built
on micro underpinnings
and a certain view of a
costly state verification
as an underlying imperfection.
It does feature a lot
the role of credit
and a financial accelerator.
But largely, with
some exceptions
I'll say momentarily, this
stuff is an aggregate of model.
And it's quite
elaborate as a model.
You have the Central Bank.
You have households,
entrepreneurs,
but entrepreneurs are somehow
different from retailers.
And retailers are somehow
different from capital goods
producers.
And certainly in early versions
of Christiano and Eichenbaum,
and so on, they actually
only look at the aggregates
generated by that model.
They never they never assign
these sectors to data.
It's not tested.
It's not part of the way
they're doing business.
So maybe they don't need to if
they get the aggregates right,
but this is a picture of India.
This stuff is used
by central banks.
If you want to
see one in Brazil,
it's called samba or something.
I'm not sure if
that's the music.
[LAUGHTER]
They have one.
It's on the reading list.
But I must say, in a bit
more optimistic vein,
things are starting
to come together.
Hsieh and Klenow wrote
papers on India and China
on the distribution
of firm size.
And now it's almost
becoming standard
that if you write down
one of these models,
you have to look at the
implication for firm size.
Or some key parameter
in the model
is going to be calibrated
against the distribution
of firm sizes in
the US, for example.
Just like Rajan and
Zingales kind of
started that research path.
So the latest Larry paper
definitely uses that,
and uses other
financial variables,
starting to look at
bankruptcy, and so on.
So one can be
somewhat optimistic
that these seemingly
similar, in the sense
of general equilibrium,
but obviously diverse
attacks on how the financial
system work, or isn't
even necessarily model.
They're kind of coming together.
And I think the place where
it arguably has come together
the fastest, and where we really
quite understand quite a lot is
in development economics.
And it features the measurement
at the household level
using corporate accounts.
This is again the midpoint
of the series of lectures.
So we can get at TFP,
productivity change, wealth,
rates of return,
treating households
just like the firms are
treated in corporate financial
accounts, income statement,
balance sheet, statement
of cash flow.
Occupation choice is a key
ingredient in these models,
because typically in
developing countries,
you see households
making transitions.
They used to be in agriculture.
They set up a firm, maybe
become wage earners.
So that's a big part of
almost all of the models.
There's tests of these
micro underpinnings.
I listed a few papers here.
There's some warning that
underpinnings do matter,
that things are rare.
It's rarer that one
kind of underpinning
is a stand-in for
the other ones,
or at least it does not
always work out that way,
and the Matsuyama paper
is a pretty good reminder.
Well, actually he more says
things aren't monotonic.
And Boyd and Smith
and Gertler and Rogoff
have examples of how
these underpinnings really
matter to the macro or
regional phenomenon.
So part of-- part of the
agenda here is measurement,
and it's not just measurement
at the household level.
It moves from the national
income accounts and balance
sheets, and so on, to
differences of balance sheets,
so it's essentially
the flow of funds.
So if there's one thing that
seems obvious, but actually
remains challenging,
is that if you
wanted to model the financial
system in a country,
you should look at the
flow of funds data.
Because that really tells
you, at least at the level
of aggregation that is
presented in the public data,
what financial instruments
are actually used,
who's taking the debtor-lender
position in those instruments.
You can certainly see
very well with flow
of funds, the
movement in and out
of the formal financial system.
Because that's where the
measurement is the best,
actually, because banks
have to report stuff.
They try desperately
to hide a lot,
but at least flow of funds in
and out of the banking system
is available even for
low income countries.
Turns out the IMF
is loaded with data.
People at the fund
haven't been using it.
But now it's sort
of an awakening
that there's a lot of
things that could be
done with flow of funds data.
And I'm in touch
with those guys,
so potentially if
you're interested
in a particular country, get you
the latest flow of funds data.
You have to keep
an eye on things,
though, in the sense
of the informal sector
is typically not measured,
but in these countries
can be really key, especially
in low income countries.
And unfortunately,
you don't usually
get the geography,
although we've
had some projects we've
encouraged with Mexico
and are kind of
working with Brazil
to get the geography in there.
We'll come back to this
flow of funds diagram,
but it basically makes the
point that you can talk about--
Here is actually a village
again with the transactions
of the village with a
not-for-profit corporation,
financial corporations,
non-financial corporations,
and government, and so on.
So just to belabor
the point again,
the way that you measure
in principle is common.
And then you can zoom
in and out depending
on what you think might be
key, and take a look at orders
of magnitudes of things.
You may not realize it,
but I'm basically following
the order of the syllabus.
So after we get through
the measurement part,
including flow of funds,
we'll talk specifically
about micro level tests
of insurance, of credit.
This is too
complicated for today,
but we'll get into these
obstacles to trade,
and how to test whether
it's a moral hazard problem
or adverse selection problem.
Test incomplete markets
against information
constrained markets.
This is a lot of material,
and I'll be mindful of that.
I'll at least try to give
you some examples of how
this analysis is
being conducted.
And we end up back with Applied
General Equilibrium Development
Economics, which is going to be
you know what we're going to do
in class starting on Thursday.
We're going to start with--
we've already got the reduced--
the patient choice models.
There are several Banerjee
Newman, [INAUDIBLE],,
Lloyd-Ellis and Dan
Bernhardt, Aghion and Bolton.
The key parameters of the
financial underpinning.
We'll for the second
lecture of the class,
we will be sort of having all
the ingredients, the micro,
the estimation,
and the simulation.
This is another sort of
genre in the literature.
This is financial--
this one takes
the expansion of the
financial system as exogenous.
This one tries to
make it endogenous.
Key contributors
are, say for example,
Greenwood and Jovanovic,
[INAUDIBLE] and Smith.
Entirely theoretical models
basically in the style
of Ross Levine, taking a stand
on how intermediation works,
showing, for example, that
inequality might go up
before it goes down,
but not taken seriously
enough in the sense of going to
the data, which is what we'll
talk about next time.
I said quite a bit during
the lecture about policy
and assessing policy.
So Thailand, for
example, as you saw,
had financial deepening
going on, and at times,
rather substantial
financial deepening.
Once we have these models
and we've kind of estimated
or calibrated the
key parameter, we
can do these
welfare experiments.
We can actually say, who
benefited, and for that matter,
who lost from the expansion
of the financial system?
The beneficiaries are like
these poor credit constrained
households that don't have
access to the financial system.
But over time, as
they exogenously
are allowed to
enter that system,
they have huge increases in
their welfare and well-being.
Why does somebody lose?
Well, that growth of enterprise
means increased employment.
It's pressure on wages.
In the model and in Thailand,
the real wage eventually
shoots up rather dramatically.
That increases the
cost of doing business
and the profits of
entrepreneurs can drop.
So this is the wonderful part.
Now, I don't mean to say
this model is wonderful.
It has a lot of
limitations, which I will
share with you on Thursday.
But what's wonderful about
it is that you can actually
go through these distributive
welfare gains and losses
types of calculations.
This one with endogenous
financial deepening
comes back to my comment
on the slide which
had India versus Thailand,
and I said something obscure
about I had another view of
what happened in Thailand.
Well, part of that growth
was preceded by a real flat.
GDP went basically flat-lined.
And what was going on?
Well, they had certain interest
rate restrictions on deposit
rates and lending rates.
There was an oil shock.
Prices were going up,
and money was flowing out
of the financial system.
The banks ran into trouble.
The government essentially
took them over,
and the economy goes flat-line.
You should worry about this.
It's not necessarily the
case that quote, regulation,
or in this case,
national-- almost close
to nationalization
of the banking system
is necessarily the way to deal
with the financial crisis.
Now how on earth are
we able to model this?
It's really quite simple.
We just create a wedge
in the original Greenwood
and Jovanovic model,
which is the spread
between the borrowing
and lending rate.
And we say when the more the--
sorry, this sounds
very market-oriented--
the more the government
does, the more resources
gets squandered, and
that inefficiency wedge
kind of increases over and above
the cost of intermediation.
And at the calibrated
parameters,
that's actually enough for the
model simulation to go flat.
But likewise, then we can
liberalize the system, which
Thailand did, and back out.
And then we'll go way
beyond these two the lecture
next Tuesday.